whatever he goes the cameras the
controversy and the circus follows a
performance with a former president at
the start of the show
Donald Trump is back in the UK for the
first time in four years
it's great to be home he said a
reference to his ancestral Roots after
all his mother grew up on Scotland's
Western Isles
personal rather than political trip for
Donald Trump arriving here in Scotland
at a time when he becomes the first U.S
president in history to be facing
criminal charges
it was the moment Trump the businessman
arrived at his nearby Golf Resort time
to forget the trial he faces over
alleged hush money payments
I'm welcome does not extend too far this
the message to a president from some of
his aberdeenshire neighbors
was he welcome here or not uh no uh to
be honest with you the first time he
came you know he just caused so much
problems he forced people out the houses
don't see the problem with Donald Trump
been here a businessman brings a lot to
the community and you've got the hat for
it as well yes I've had this hat for six
years so I've always been a supporter
here is Trump at his other Resort in
airshow a few years ago a Scottish
business Empire facing financial
problems the latest accounts revealing
4.4 million pound losses I think this is
part of sort of separating his political
Ambitions this is more focused on his
business Ambitions in trying to
revitalize these businesses I think
which again as I said have been
suffering a little bit over the last
couple of years it all comes down with
Donald Trump it all comes down to
perception into publicity and I think
he's hoping that this visit will give a
boost of publicity to his golf courses
I'm not sure how successful that will be
this fleeting visit to the UK may be a
moment of relief for Donald Trump and he
will hope boost his business's bottom
line there are though plenty of
questions for him back home as he
battles to get back in to the White
House Conor Gillis Sky News
aberdeenshire